welcome to scitrik your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so yesterday the picard series 2 trailer
dropped
and let's go through this there was
obviously star trek day so we always get
something juicy on star trek day and the
picard series 2 is no exception
the advert i have to admit does look
stunning but i was very excited by the
end of it for card series 1 and that
left me
a little disappointed but serious two
it's looking good it's looking
old-school star trek to me
new showrunner is obviously really
helping but how does the advert start we
get the voice of darsh apparently
talking to picard
she asks him the question though will
you go out to the stars to seek
something or are you going to the stars
to run away from something now obviously
we've got the big question of what does
she mean by that but more than that as
well
it seemed odd to me the way she was
talking to picard she was talking to him
like somebody that's known him for years
his old life
where is that coming from and obviously
we know darsh is an android so
is that maybe data talking to her q then
turns up and initially it seems like
quite a
cheeky normal sort of picard q
relationship q reminds him that the
trial never ends and picard and the
advert turns he says i am too old for
this ball
q's face when it flashes back just
before he clicks
is an angry face he looks pissed what is
the conversation that they've had that
has made q do what he then does
and what he does
is create an entirely new timeline or
change earth's past he creates a
totalitarian nightmare the picard seems
to be in charge of
or at very least a well-respected
general
he's in front of a very large audience
all cheering clapping going crazy uh
non-borg seven of nine is in the
background stood like a general we see a
flash of the city and a large explosion
at top of one of the tall buildings
perhaps that building collapsing in
we then see two romulans running down a
little dark alley
is this a hint that the romulans just
attacked the earth that this is some
sort of terror attack we have to wonder
maybe is the romulan plight paralleled
in this universe that they still lost
their homeworld that they've been maybe
took into this new federational empire
this new totalitarian federation
perhaps the romulans in this are the
good guys and the federation are the bad
guys something that we've seen in mirror
universes before
so then picard realizes they have to go
back in time to change this terrible
nightmare and for some reason they have
three days to do it don't know why but
it makes for a good plotline always was
it deadline or is it deadlines exciting
isn't it and it seems to me from the
trailer that they're going to use the
borg to do that and they go to see the
ball queen
there is some very confusing flashing
images here of memories and and all this
sort of thing that's obviously going to
maybe
convince the queen to help or do
something else or you know explain the
plot i'm sure the cutis is going to come
into this somehow but we haven't seen
that yet in the trailer
the queen is very different and we've
talked
in a previous video actually about how
the new showrunner has worked on comics
for um star trek in the past and in
those comics the queen looks regularly
very very different actually
significantly more like this in the
trailer than the ball queen we're used
to in the past we then see flashes of
the
time travel technology or whatever else
and they appear back in time on the 21st
century earth
they could be here now how could that be
john lupercard turning up for a cup of
tea
i haven't got any on grey you're gonna
have to actually drink a proper cup of
tea sorry we then see a few flashes of
the relationship between seven and rafi
and i think that's going to really be a
nice bit of fun through this series and
you know we need a bit of fun in star
trek there should be a bit of humor and
it does look like we're going to get
that with this sort of
buddy copy movie type of love hate
relationship between the two of them it
should give a nice bit of comic relief
and an interesting element to the
characters
in the video we then see a little flash
of q again and again he is
clicking something into being
and he's wearing a earth type outfit but
there was a very large prominent europa
badge on his chest what does that mean
because
it was so prominent it's got to mean
something i do see several more flashes
with darsh she seems to be in some woods
there seems to be a romulan with them
and another another figure we're not
sure they seem to be running or hiding
from something i wonder if this is going
to play into this sort of terrorist
feel or vibe or freedom fighter vibe
that the romulans are probably going to
be encompassing
the one little bit as well is the dratty
part in this they have a little bit of a
joke
i'm not a huge fan of her character she
was quite important for the first series
but you kind of understand why she was
there because she was an expert
in the android technology and she knew
the
how the android was constructed and
things but i'm really wondering where
they're going to go with her character
now um i have a little bit of a
i do feel like she's a little bit of a
nothing character and she's a bit of a
whiner and you know
i'm not a huge fan of her character and
we'll put it that way but it will be
interesting to see where she goes and
she does bring an emotional element to
the series that maybe the others don't
the others maybe just like get to go on
with our job and she's actually like the
heart of it so she has the emotions and
we see that again we see her talking to
the ball queen
and the ball queen by the way seems to
be imprisoned
or injured or something like this she's
she's not she can't she's not walking on
her leg she's she's only like that part
of her body and she's on sort of ropes
that are hanging off the thing and so
we don't even know how she finds the
ball queen as well to be fair that's
another interesting point where they
even come across her she's not in the
first series is she bought the q is she
bought the cube is seven of nine because
of what happened at the end of series
one able to find her but anyway she
seems to be imprisoned somewhere somehow
and jarati is talking to her and zarate
seems generally upset
and tears almost and the ball queen is
just reaching out to touch her face
she's dratty seems sympathetic towards
the ball queen and i would say that's a
really stupid idea don't do that you're
going to get assimilated you stupid
woman
so
let's see how about pans out
the big thought i had from this
from this trailer is that this series
feels like a crossover between star trek
nemesis
the borg going back in time to change
the earth's past
and the voyage home
them having to fly back and cling on
warbird to go and get whales from the
20th century to bring back to
save the future it was a ridiculous
premise but it was probably my favorite
star trek movie um maybe
undiscovered country is probably the
favorite because that was the first one
i ever saw the cinema but there's a
movie voyager fantastic film
this
this the parts definitely where the
picard series 2 is in the 21st century
just gave me that vibe it gave me that
voyage home vibe and i wonder how many
little easter eggs or tributes to that
movie which is considered a classic
let's be honest we're gonna get in the
series i'd love to see a few little nods
to that movie please like and subscribe
hit that bell notification it really
helps us out and you know if you want to
leave a comment to tell us what you're
hoping to see from pecan series 2 i'd
love to know what you think